Thanks so I would like also to thank the
organizers of this PI data this is my
second year attending and giving dog
here and it's been always great and also
thank you to stay here at the last block
of the last day I would like to talk
about not just about my Julia library
but also like to talk about a theory
called light field theory that some of
you might not hear about so basically
the main the main goal of this talk is
to present a novel technique to
reconstruct the depth map of a scene
from a limited number of views and what
I mean by that is I want to recover the
death of some points in a scene from
taking different pictures of the same
scene and this can be applied and this
is broadly applied in view synthesis and
rendering for free viewpoint virtual
reality which is basically an immersive
virtual reality where you can enter to a
room from where you take the pictures
and then move around the room because
you know the depth of the different
features in the room I want to also
explain the main building blocks of this
technique which is the light field and
shifflet's and show a free hardware
software implementation using julia
Python and Raspberry Pi so last year I
don't know if some of you went to my
talk I basically talked about a Euler
library there I develop for
multi-dimensional a signal processing
which is called Schlup Dajjal
and this is going to be used here so for
al for a whole year I think about some
interesting applications of this library
and this was one that really caught my
attention so first of all what is a
light field so how many of you have
heard of this light field theory maybe
none yeah okay cool so this is based on
the fact that light can be interpreted
as a field a field is just an assignment
of a vector to each point in this space
this was this was proposed by Michael
Faraday actually nowadays we know that
light can be interpreted both us a field
or as a particle
so propagation of light rays in the 3d
space is can be completely described by
a seven dimensional continuous function
that I will call l and this Emily
national continuous function is known as
the plenoptic function and basically
describes the how much the light is
expanding around the the space in a
point XY sea with two three dimensional
angles theta and V and wavelength lambda
and period tau you can see the this
dysfunction you can visualize it as as
in this diagram
so since computing a seven dimensional
function is really a complex task one
can actually reduce the complexity of
the problem by simplifying the the plan
opting function into a four dimensional
function that is known as the light
field and this quantifies the intensity
of a static and monochromatic light ray
is propagating in half space so
basically what you do is you fee you fix
the wavelength that's where the
monochromatic comes from you fix the the
one of the angles and you also fix one
of the of the special variables there
are different representations or
different ways to parameterize this
light field one is for example taking
points in a surface a point in a surface
is described by two variables and then
measuring the two angles the three
dimensional angles of the light that is
going out of this point the other one
you can actually also parameterize the
light field by the intersection of the
light rays in the sphere two points are
also described by four parameters and
you can also describe the light field by
the intersection of the light rays in
two parallel planes this is the disc
this is the approach that we were going
to use today this is called two plane
parameterization
so basically if you know the value of
the light field in two parallel planes
all the points on two parallel planes
you basically just can't describe the
whole life you so but how can you go
from light field to 3d representation of
the scene well this is basically this is
based on a biology biological fact that
the human brain generates the tree be
depth perception of its surroundings by
translating the points of a scene using
the information coming from both eyes so
you basically have two planes that are
the two image planes of the eyes and you
can triangulate back to the point and
that's how your brain know whether
something is deep or not in the in the
scenario so the people are geometry is a
mathematical geometry that basically
generalizes the stereovision principle
and instead of just having two planes
you have basically a lot of different
planes and therefore you have a very
resolution of the light view and it uses
something called the be polar constraint
where you analyzes the object positions
well assuming the knowledge of the
camera motion and here I'm talking about
camera because what what you do to
actually recover light field you
basically sample the light field by
taking different pictures of the scene
that you want to recover and you can
assume that you know the position of the
camera because you are moving the camera
itself and this reduces a lot the
complexity of the problem so here in
this in this diagram I have two planes
and I have a point in the scenic a point
where I would want to recover the depth
yeah so the plane that makes the point
and the two lens centers is called the
people learn the before a plane and
points in one a people are praying
correspond to point at intersection of
one epipolar plane with the wind one of
the plane images correspond also to the
intersection of the the same a polar
plane to the other plane image so it's
really nice because you reduce this
problem to a two-dimensional problem
basically you if you want to search for
points in one line you just need to
search
for the points in the in the in the same
line corresponding to the intersection
so I'm gonna use the assumption that we
have a camera that is taking pictures of
a scene at the moves in a straight line
this reduces a lot the the way that you
can describe the light feel because
basically the people are plane just
intersect each of the image planes in
horizontal lines and when you track the
points in one of the horizontal lines
around the different views basically you
get an image that is formed by these
straight-line structures and this is
straight line this image is called a
people airplane image from this straight
line structures you can actually recover
directly the depth of the point of the
corresponding point and that's why it's
important to do this assumption so how
to recover the depth map with this
episode are the that's how I called the
a paper airplane images well if you know
the position of that point in each of
the in in each of the views you can
actually just compute the slope of the
corresponding line where this point is
and this slope is is completely related
to the death of the point by this this
formula so in order to have this kind of
images you need to take a lot of
pictures because yeah there is something
called the Nyquist Nyquist criterion
which keeps you basically a lower bound
of the sampling rate of the of the
images and in order to have high
dimensional high resolution light fields
you basically need to take tons of
hiding high-resolution pictures and
these high resolution pictures use a lot
of memory and also the computational
complexity to compute the slopes
increases so most of the people who is
working on light field actually try to
reduce the number of pictures you need
to take the recovery depth map using
something called a compress compress
light view
and this is what I want to talk about
today there are some examples of
commercial light fuel cameras that the
first one this is called neat row this
is I think that's the best known one in
the world and this comes from a start-up
in Silicon Valley and it has I mean they
actually did pretty well and now Google
Google bought them like last year the
other one this that the one below is
called rhetorics this is a German
company and it's mostly for industrial
induced reducers
so I want to show you what I want to
show you right now is an example of
image that was taken by the Litro camera
and how you can actually render the
death of the points yeah yeah so this is
an image it looks like an image was
actually a set of a lot of images how
the Litro camera works is instead of
moving the camera you have you have a
micro array of lenses so you have you
take actually different pictures in this
micro array so when I click for example
here you change the focus of the picture
I can also click here and you can
actually move the focus of the picture
whatever you want I mean this looks more
like having fun but actually is it has
some important applications for example
in cinematography because in
cinematography if you actually know the
depth of all the points in your scenes
then you don't need to use green screens
because you can actually just separate
each of the layers of the picture and
yeah literal try to to go in that
direction and create a cinema camera but
it was too too expensive if I didn't
work out so our approach here will be
something that is known as sub Nyquist
reconstruction the sub-niches
reconstruction basically reduces the
lower bone of the sampling rate that I
talked about so instead of taking a lot
of pictures you take this part set of
contiguous views and the first the first
image this
upper image is the representation of
this sparse set of different bills in
the paper airplane images this one that
I show you this this one so of course
from here you cannot recover the lines
so you cannot compute the slope because
these actually don't form lines so if
you separate them accordingly to how you
take the pictures you can actually see
that these here you can see some lines
but of course we want to do this in the
computer we want that the computer
recognizes the line so you cannot just
as for the computer to recognize these
lines that are not really there so you
need to basically feel the gaps in
between these lines somehow this is this
is an image processing task that is
known as as image in painting and I want
to explain you broadly how this works so
so the general setting of image in
painting is the task where you want to
reconstruct an image that I'm calling f
from just unknown part of the image so
you lost you lost some parts of the
image you have holes because the image
can be can be old or sometimes you don't
sample the whole the whole set and you
want to basically recover these holes
and make sense of it yeah so how to in
paint in painting is based on
mathematical concept there is known as
frame frame is just generalization of
orthonormal basis so in the frame you
actually have the possibility to to have
recurrency and this lets you compress
images so it's basically lets you that
the expansion of the image in these
bases is sparse that a lot of positions
are can be set as 0 and there are some
results on a sparse regularization and
compressed sensing maybe some of you
heard of compressed sensing what it says
that you can actually recover a signal
or an image when he says parts within a
frame you can recover it from a highly
undetermined height
non-adaptive linear measurements in
other words you can in paint an image by
knowing a sparse representation of this
image and just deleting the coefficients
are not so important some frames for
images some non-friends for images are
these for example governs wavelet frames
which are the most the most widely known
and for example the compression
algorithm on JPEG 2000 space of whale
wavelet frames
cubelet frames and then the last one
shielded frames which was proposed by
geeta Coutinho and is the one that I
mostly use there is a result presented
by Donahoe which says basically tells
you how sparse can you actually get a
frame on certain space in this case the
space that I'm talking about is known as
cartoon-like functions and this is the
space that best describe images so what
it says is like you cannot have a frame
from which it's the projection of the
image in this frame goes so the case
faster than n to the minus 1 the
wavelets do not cannot specify pretty
well images they actually can just get n
to the minus 1/2 and the reason for this
is that wavelets just describe isotropic
features of the images so like like
squared blobs so you need something that
can describe also directional features
of the images so non square blobs for
but like edges and the wavelets ton
describe H is pretty well that's why you
need to use something that also changes
the orientation of the elements so
basically in this case sheerly transform
is just a transform or a filtering based
on on generating functions where you
basically what you basically do is you
have a windows function that will take
the information special information of
the
and then you also change the size of
this windows function this is known as
the scaling this is the first the first
matrix and this this change of size lets
you have also a special information of
the image like very localized special
information of the image in other in
terms you can get some holes by knowing
how this change of size behaves and then
you have something called the shearing
and the shearing just change the
orientation of these windows so then you
can also have directional information of
the image a slight modification of this
system called the corner optical a
transfer where you can when you actually
divide say the fourier space in
different cones and then you you take
the [ __ ] transform in each of these
coins it gets this bound given by Donoho
so basically she let's are a good frame
to specify images and as well as a good
frame to compress images and that's what
i'm using it so this is basically the
follower pipeline that I use for depth
map estimation first of all you acquire
a rectified image sequence which is
taking in a straight line so you
basically take camera and you take
images that are equally distance between
another and after that you need to
follow the points you need to track the
points in these images to see how fast
they move in between the images so this
is the principle where you can that I
use talked in the people are plain
images where you can actually get the
depth of the point by knowing the slope
of the lines and this slope of the lines
is related to the velocity of the points
in the dip in the sequence of the images
so points are closer to you we look that
they look fast they move faster than
points are further away from you of
course for that you need to somehow
recognize features on the image so not
everything is easy to track for example
in this blackboard if you take a picture
of this blackboard
cannot track points in this blog where
all of them looked like the same so you
first of all need to need to detect
points that are easy to drag on these
points are corners so I use the sheet of
massey algorithm which is implementing
in OpenCV these openly open source
library for computer vision in python
and then you need to track the points
for this i just use the Lucas Kannada
algorithm I can give you I did actually
my master thesis on this so I can give
you also that if you want to know more
of the mathematics behind these
algorithms and then you get by this by
just sampling sparsely the abuse of the
of the scene you get an initial sparse
if we put our plane image from which you
cannot get recognized or detect the
lines and therefore you need to
reconstruct the dense version of this
you need to in paint you need to fill
the gaps in between the blues and from
that I use
she let in painting and then at the end
you need to basically detect the lines
and then compute the slope of the lines
and for that I used a half line
transform so for the parts of computer
vision like corner detection point
tracking and depth map estimation I use
OpenCV in Python because the julia
version was in the july api is not so
good and then for the the whole other
part for let's say did the the in
painting I use Julia the data said that
I use is a sequin of 101 rectified
pictures of a scene generated by a
professor in the Disney Research Center
in sewage they also work with light
field they actually have really nice
results on high resolution light field
the technical details of the physical
setup this is a physical syrup so well
it's a canon camera and is the you move
the canon camera in a motorized linear
stage that will take the picture
we'll move the camera to the each of the
views that you want to get and this is
the first image and this is the second
image it doesn't look so different
but with this sorry this is the first
image and this is the last image of the
sequence doesn't look so difference but
with this difference you can actually
recover the depth pretty well so you
don't really need to have a huge set up
these are the points that I could detect
there were actually I think there were
340 points that I could detect and track
and this is the traces that they did in
the different views in until the last
image so in order to get the people
airplane images that I talked about from
which you can compute the slopes and
then the depth of the points I took
horizontal bands of points and then if
you track them the whole way until the
until the last image you get things like
this where the different colors are
different features that I hand-picked
but you don't really need to do that and
then if you just use as I say an sparse
sampling of the scene you get something
like this which reduces a lot the time
and the complexity so this is one
example on the results and then this is
the sparse version and this is the in
painted version that I get using
shallots and from which I can use hoc
transform to detect the lines so I
desired the lines right detector here
and then the corresponding death map is
basically this and from here the issues
a color map representation of the death
map where the lighter elements are the
one that are closest closer and the
other that the darker elements are the
ones that are not so so close yeah so
yeah I would like to show you this a
little bit how this work this is quite
an early version of
of the project because this is basically
now my side project of the PhD so I try
to make it as reproducible as possible
but it's still not so not sort of stable
so basically the only leverage that I
used was numpy CV open CV matplotlib
pandas and yeah basically that's it so
yeah so there is a lot of examples
actually in Internet where you four
point tracking using using the Lucas
Kannada algorithm and you can get but
what gives you is basically gives you a
list of the position of the points in
each of the times where you track them
and the this image was pretty nice
because has a lot of a lot of corners
but if I I try also with an image that
has not much corners like this and it
can you can just drag like six points so
this is not so nice for for depth map
recovery then after tracking the points
I basically yeah
so I basically can get this parse this
parse ap and using the Sheila Tim
painting
wait yeah well yes I get something like
this so maybe since I have some time I
can explain you somehow how this in
painting works so
and you have a hole here
where you don't know where is inside
this hole it like intuitively it has a
tree inside so you cannot really do note
that this image almost all the pictures
here are all the pixels here are equally
important so you need to transform its
image to a space where you have a sparse
sparse representations of where the
coefficients or the values of this
representation are mostly 0 and this is
the shieldlands
so the ship is basically where the dough
is they take just the edges here most of
the image are sparse in HS therefore you
can kill a lot of the other confirmation
of that and then if the information of
the image if the information lost in
this hole is not so important then by
use basically it smoothing out it
erratically around here something called
interrupted periscoping
you can actually recover this something
that looks that make sense here of
course if you have a face so yeah so
this this project was basically
motivated because when I try to learn
about these these methods like like
field theory and how to implement them I
found that we the by blogger Dave a
biography that is available online it's
not it's kind of a secure because has a
lot of like industrial interests behind
and I couldn't really get an open source
code that tells you how to end to end
reconstructed that map that's why that's
why I did this project so I tried to do
it by myself
and I ended up finding out that wasn't
that wasn't that hard and I also was
motivated because most of the come light
field cameras are pretty expensive if
that goes like at least 1,000 euros and
it really doesn't look like it should be
so expensive because the the
mathematical concept behind it are not
so complex so I think why not to you to
do also a hardware implementation of
this so you just need Python you need
Julia and you need a camera that's the
only thing you need basically and
Raspberry Pi has off all of that so
Raspberry Pi has a julia has also Python
and there is a camera a camera that you
can connect to the Raspberry Pi this
thing I actually have it here but yeah
right now is still an early version so a
lot of things are crashing but the idea
here is what I did was you can take
pictures using this camera and moving it
in a truck and then the whole the whole
libraries that I use run inside here and
they do it automatically so instead of
paying 1000 euros for a light-filled
camera this thing costs at most seven 70
euros so the future were what I would
like to do in the future if I have time
because not not not everybody wants you
to do this like at least I asked I asked
to my advisor if I would like to do this
but she wasn't that sure that she could
help me in this so here at least here in
Berlin I don't know where could I work
with somebody that to light view and my
future what I like to do is basically
dive in the rendering part so so far I
can just compute the depth but then I
would like to render the scene because
if you grab the dev of
the points are of the features you can
actually reconstruct the 3d version of
the pictures that you're taking and this
is something that Google is doing right
now they use something called they have
a project called project tango and they
also have other projects where they are
trying to create in mersive media so you
can interact 3d in a 3d setting with
create environments yeah basically I
would like just to show you that this
this field is quite it's quite
interesting and it's not so real it's
not really so hard to enter and I think
has a lot of industrial opportunities
and yeah that should be thank you thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Hector for her interesting
talk
do you have any questions from audience
thanks a lot for the great presentation
Hector
so photography is a little bit my my
passion and I was you know observing
pretty closely the the launch of the
Lytro camera probably I don't know four
years ago five years ago and then
nothing happened really and one of the
things I observed was I mean the the
resolution was fairly poor and there
wasn't you know in terms of its it's a
something you try and you know you play
around with it a couple of times and
then you're done I mean it's kind of
nice to change the focus but the
application was missing and and also the
resolution what I mean if you do this
with your Raspberry Pi do you get the
normal resolution of the camera or you
haven't done that yet right the the
reconstruction you have done it but what
can you show was a picture yes wait I
mean I have been a heaven I have right
now not example with the Raspberry Pi
camera but I have a this example of this
picture that I mean this picture is of
resolution 512 times 512 and you can do
the reconstruction using these sequence
of pictures so it will be this it will
apply the same for the raspberry camera
pictures but this is I mean you use the
Canon mark for us yes the original
resolution is much higher what what do
you do with the rest of the information
I subsample the images to get a lower
resolution so so far for I mean this
this algorithm works for any resolution
it will just take more time for higher
resolutions because then you need to
track more points you have more points
to track so there is not really a limit
of the resolution okay maybe just the
time and also they you had the problem
with the Raspberry Pi basically is that
this is the Raspberry Pi 3 and it has 1
gigabyte of RAM and you cannot really
fit a lot of stuff there so what I
needed to do
- basically for example the filters that
I use for [ __ ] let's I needed to first
create them somewhere else and then save
them in a hdf5 file and then just put
them inside here this they work for any
any image so you don't really need to
compute them on the fly and that's yeah
that's are some of the limitations of
the Raspberry Pi in is crashing a lot
that's that's really a problem I mean
let's say two or three times that I try
to run the reconstruction in the
Raspberry Pi crashes and the other
question I had was just from a contrast
perspective you mentioned the blackboard
which obviously you cannot differentiate
with your shield and the the Lytro they
do it by the micro array where they
detect the angle of the of the light
initially I think so they don't have
that limitation yes what are your
thoughts how you how do you want to
further develop that area yeah that's
true
I mean my approach is poor in the sense
when you don't have too much corners
drag yeah I don't know I I was mostly
inspired on the approach of the Disney
research center in sewage and they use
this so they track points so I'm not I
think you they they the people in Litro
they get the direction of the light rays
by this micro array of lenses this
doesn't work here so yeah that's that's
downside yeah yeah yeah I'm not
completely sure how the Lytro Lytro
camera works
I know there is the the PhD theses of
Ren the guy who was the CEO of nitro and
I think he he explains pretty well
they're they're rendering and that will
be my next step to read how to render
light field
I think do you have any other questions
maybe I asked you do you have any plan
to release the hardware that you I
create it and if it's like so
competitive in comparison with
commercial stuff do you think that it
will be worth to try to make some
embedded device out of it and and ship
it to market I mean actually I think
there is a lot of potential in that
because also it's not I mean this this
hardware this low-cost camera doesn't
have just the possibility of to
enlighten reconstruction but you also
have a lot of different stuff they're
already implemented in OpenCV that are
already used in raspberry-pi cameras so
you will have a like a super camera with
low ram basically but I was mostly
inspired by the open-source community
and I as such I just open sourced
everything and so anybody that wants to
apply it can can just do it I don't I
don't plan to sell or anything that's
really cool thank you and maybe one more
thing but I'd like to ask maybe not
directed to the whole project but in
general why Julia okay
yeah so this is most mostly historical
so I I studied my bachelor in in Mexico
and my supervisor there was a huge Julia
developer I mean fan let's say he's very
involved in the Julia project and he
convinced me to use you and I really
liked it
I'm not completely so close-minded to
just say Julia is the greatest thing so
I use my daily life different things but
I do like I do enjoy to to program India
and it's for a lot of applications is
super easy and fast so yeah I mean I
think for example for this signal
processing library chillip is it was
pretty easy to implement it in you and
so far is the fastest implement
of this [ __ ] letting transform and it
was really easy to do it so yeah I think
it's also a good language programming in
which to start with if you have to know
if you have no no experience with
programming Python and Julia are very
similar so if you program in Python it
was completely automatic you can program
in MATLAB I mean Julia was was designed
for mathematicians to make them stop
using MATLAB basically yeah and that's
yeah I like I like that idea
thanks a lot so we still have plenty of
time guys any other questions from the
audience then once again thank you oh
sorry I didn't
so thanks for the talk I was wondering
in the setup you have there the way I
understood it you need to know pretty
exactly how the camera moved and how the
pictures were taken in relations one to
another for end-user applications you
usually wouldn't have that so if you try
to do that on a smartphone camera for
example is that a next step for you or
can you comment on how possible or
impossible that is with this technique
so my approach explicitly uses the abuse
or photos taken by a camera who moves in
a straight line and a straight line
which is actually orthonormal to the
lens axis so that's that's the only way
it was gonna work that's one of also one
of the downsides so in a smartphone you
like you will need then that the camera
of the smartphone you can move move in a
straight line along the smartphone that
would work but that's kind of cringe
that's kind of not it's not so
comfortable for sure so yeah it doesn't
doesn't really work for I mean my idea
was this in this thing to have a track
which moves in a straight line and by
doing that I basically broke the camera
so yeah I'm not completely sure yet how
to how to make it easier way I mean in
this setup you have is huge
so you have a track which is huge and
also a camera so of course that is not
for and like for commercial applications
yeah and maybe other applications that I
didn't okay yeah I was just to mention
other applications that I didn't say of
light-filled for example there is
something called light field microscopy
or you can if you recover the light
field of alpha imagine a microscope with
different focus then you can I mean they
I think some people use this to have
like so two separate elements in
in the objective of the microscope and
yeah also I thought about this cinema
cinematography application where you can
separate the layers of the images and
then you don't need to use a green green
screen and things like that that will
will reduce the cost of prosperous of
post-processing of cinematography
because for example if you're out of
focus you're not really you're not
really worried about because you can
change the focus anyway yes but just
follow-up question on that comment if
you for example with your DSLR take the
picture you want to make sure that
everything is in focus yes which is kind
of contradictory to using a larger
sensor at some point and also to allow
short exposure times and you also need
rectified images so you need to first
rectify them that's all yeah yeah that's
true there's a lot of downsides but the
worst deal was kind of a cool project to
do very cool any more questions
then once again thank you very much for
the talks and now guys
you